keddy c'est votre anniversaire hier soir
vous êtes allé à disney avec toi ouais
vos amis avec une amie à vous any time
voilà ce qu'on avait là on a des vidéos
de cette belle soirée et attention
regardez bien à la fin de la séquence de
les voir il y en a une qui était
déchaîné c'est christine kelly oui c'est
une qualité puisqu'elle a quitté le csa
ce qu'on appelle dans le milieu une ni
comment elles passent de pas dans son
match 16 heures la première chose ça
n'est pas coté et le soir c'est nu
combat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arriba
on fait tous rêver comme des petits
pains
[Applaudissements]
elle s'amuse mais n'oublie jamais quel
os et sa météo ces satanés toujours en
librairie ce qu'on appelle la mini raz
sera on a donné deux petits farceurs nos
petits boutons train maxime et kelly
qu'on fait une petite blague
blaga doc gynéco qui était allé au m
alors lui vous alors donc on n'avait pas
dormi de la journée non les gars le
matin quand vous réveiller aussi toi
keller savais pas 9 heures et lui se
réveiller à 9h pour lui c'est comme
quand nous en avions à 6 heures du matin
se réveille à 3 heures c'est lui sans
rigoler quoi mes frères ça va décalage
horaire mais oui c'était super disney
c'est un train un endroit extraordinaire
dissipe amis qui toi je l'aimé bien
j'ai découvert j'ai failli avoir l'aider
le gadget des oreilles tout le monde
là-bas se balade avec ça sur la terre
c'est merveilleux tout cas tu fais toi
s'il cherche quelqu'un pour faire la pub
pour disney tu serait la bonne
vers 6 h 30 à 9 heures ce soir au parc
astérix
ah ouais bah oui alors vous allez vous
parce qu'avec votre moustache
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et tu peux ramener ou alors elle fuit
les attractions les motards ou bien tu
vas faire des photos tout à l'heure ça
alors les chercheurs ont regardé nos
petits farceurs regardez ce qu'ils ont
fait tu as fait en train de la mine a
fait croire à dak que c'était le train
qui fait le tour du parc donc à une
politique tout en fait
[Musique]
tu avais pas
c'est l'anniversaire kenny et bravo vous
avez des amours et bien oui mention à
quelque chose j'ai effacé le texto parce
que voilà mais c'est très mignon ce
matin je dis bon anniversaire elle m'a
répondu je ne veux aucun cadeau que tu
me fasses l'amour c'était pas et
isabelle vous êtes déjà ton iphone ans
et ses beaux et allah est alors ça va
vivre ça va être quand baba j'ai déjà
brésil tout-va plomb plus battu rien
faire ou quoi donner du temps pour elle
excusez moi mais vous n'en parle pas du
tout vous là vous êtes fait il ya déjà
machin wayma franche avec cannibales
dans ton émission et moi je vais je vais
là je vais je faire ça pour bientôt
semaine prochaine ou très bien et ben
vous étiez c'est toi qui décide c'est
pas bien sûr n'est demandé
creton demande c'est lui qui dit merci
en tout cas fait une belle entrée
j'avais une deuxième médaille d'or
non c'est bon merci à la frénésie
s'égrènent les bêtes mais vous fait rire
comme chez amt aura de gucht a fait
arrêter par la police non hasard que
j'étais en voiture et la vie de descend
donc évidemment genre donc là vous des
cds sans la vitre ouais je fais ce que
je fais souvent évidemment j'enlève mes
lunettes comme superman
zelaya attendait sa cabine tiens le
connard bon je vois qu'à pas beaucoup
d'effet et du coup je rajoute cette
phrase je dis pardon je ferai un petit
peu la voie des bus tice est très en
retard
je vais faire ma prestation de co
animateur à tpm peco animateurs et
c'était une femme le regarde et qui me
dit pardon je sais pas qui vous êtes et
je me suis dit je suis tombé sur la flic
en europe qui me connaît pas la belgique
doit aller où c'est quoi il fallait y
retourner
javadoc suis d'accord il merci il se
mêle pas de combat